yeah he'll probably like land the final
blow on him and then that'll make them
have like
like okay all right work together good
yeah he'll do one of those like
t-rex jaw rip fist bump and then create
an atomic blast
exploding high five right yeah
see buildings being obliterated people
being
disintegrated
[Music]
what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch from our buddy chris over at
3c films
harry cheeks versus clifford lizard 2021
mechagodzilla fully revealed there are
no more secrets
we are going to see what mech godzilla
looks like baby oh yeah i'm especially
excited to check this out because i just
started up godzilla vs mechagodzilla
i believe the 70s is when it's from so
yeah let's get into action people
look here i'm supposed to be napping
like a 70 year old man late in the day
so i can watch wanda vision at 2 a.m
but this right here this is more
important
i understand especially for your channel
our best
full reveal of mechagodzilla thanks to
some leaked promotional artwork has
landed online of what this is
gonna be looking like it really should
be no surprise or secret that
mechagodzilla is part of godzilla vs
kong at this point they should just
release a trailer with him in it to hype
people more up and get people going to
the theater subscribing to hbo max
if you really do consider this to be a
spoiler i'm sorry but all the clues are
there okay not only did they already
confirm that they're going to use the
godor ahead
as they already said it the filmmakers
themselves showed us a behind the scenes
still
of the inside control room for
mechagodzilla so guys i'm gonna need
your opinions down below on what you
think of this design do you like this
look from mexico way to create
engagement chris
way do we create engagement i gotta
comment right now
who do you think will be the one to make
that final blow to kill
that kind of leaked it funko does like
to mess around with the design so it
wasn't perfect right here
this is as good as this yeah that is
metal holy [ __ ]
whoa godzilla counterpart i think this
design
is so cool right here oh i think it's
cool too
that is really cool hold on let me pull
up a photo of
emoji mechagodzilla yes bring that tin
man over here
all right here you guys go look at that
ah this is a side by side right here for
you guys
wow minor adjustments mate
that looks like zack snyder took over
and all this red stylization just looks
like blood
oh that looks so like you say metal i
mean yeah it is metal
it's literally metal and it feels metal
you know
oh that is awesome oh that looks really
threatening
so cool i don't know how you guys are
feeling on the three finger ninja turtle
hands like they're giving him
part of me stick
still i think this is a really great
design and these are some real high-res
photos of it looking at it this
definitely seems to be like the creature
we saw
in the beginning of the trailer that was
first released to us
it feels like an early stage of godzilla
maybe like a concept
art or something i'm hoping we get to
see some of those missiles or if they're
we're able to replicate some sort of
atomic breath since they're using
the ghidorah head prototype they're
being held in here
and what kind of special metal are you
using on this robot right here because i
know godzilla and kong can really break
apart
a lot of metals on earth i wouldn't be
surprised i have so many thoughts about
this some alien material just to kind of
hype up the monster universe a little
more one thing also to know about this
mega godzilla thanks to the set visit
done by comicbookmovie.com is we know
that he's going to be giving off this
signal
that is going to be driving godzilla
wild in the movie and that's why
he kind of goes bad and is tearing apart
all these different places because he
knows ghidorah in some form is still out
there and he's looking his hardest to
try and find him and kill him
all to find out it's going to be mecha
godzilla this is definitely the thing
that's going to get godzilla and kong to
stop
fighting one another to me i'm just
gonna be really curious to how they
handle that execution you know by the
end of it is godzilla and khan going to
be teaming up going double time on
mechagodzilla
or is khan going to get his butt whooped
by mechagodzilla and then godzilla has
to come in to take down him and then
through problems now
i have a pretty godzilla one in that
fight since he killed the thing that was
almost gonna feel like i know what's
going on
in the front of this shirt right here i
have a theory mega godzilla
ultimate destroyer that's an interesting
thing right there did apex purposely
make this thing to be a destroyer like
i have to think if you're a company
making courses
making it look like the thing that goes
around and terrorizing
it's an interesting choice to say the
least but also just that phrasing right
there
ultimate destroyer it's purposely being
made to destroy things and take things
down
part of me even wants to go ahead and
say is this kind of like a hint
to destroy you in the monster universe
in this design or even mechagodzilla
himself yeah i find it funny because
as we saw in one of the tv spots uh
alexander skarsgard's character
he has a mug that says monarch on it so
like monarch has their own merch in a
way yeah
so i feel like apex is now gonna have
their own t-shirt
you get your mecha godzilla ultimate
destroyer that's why a lot of recruits
have come in just for the t-shirts alone
i don't think that will be the actual
case it's just a joke pipes
but yeah i do i'm based off all this
info i feel like i have a pretty solid
theory as to how it might go down in the
end godzilla himself
to me i'm just really caught up with the
look of it i'm satisfied with it a whole
lot
i just want to see this thing full in
action it feels like it can actually
move and be flexible yeah it looks like
five minutes and then he's killed off
right away i don't know how to describe
it but yeah like this
wavy place right here but here you go
guys the secret's out
the best look of mechagodzilla we're
gonna get i think until they release the
film
at this point with all the leaks and
stuff and the movie still being about a
month away i wouldn't be surprised if
they give us
a mechagodzilla trailer i'm telling you
it would sell big bucks and it's just
not a secret anymore that he's part of
the movie so
you might as well show him off how are
you guys feeling about this leak right
here are you liking
i mean they showed us doomsday yeah
love to hear your thoughts now i'm gonna
go take that granny nap so i can get
ready for one division
see y'all in a few hours
you have some of the weird also be sure
to like and subscribe follow me on
twitter through the film review
[Laughter]
that's hilarious great focus you got man
damn i had to caught your focus right
away
oh teach me how to take an actual nap
wow
okay well i love the design the three
fingers doesn't really bother me i mean
a mechagodzilla has
four fingers yeah he's got three fingers
and a thumb
yeah right this is the photo here yeah
yeah you know it's not that big of a
departure
and it makes sense too because you know
you could probably get a lot more damage
done with like
three opposing claws rather than a kind
of
humanoid hand well i was also thinking
when
michael godzilla was announced to be in
here i was like okay how will he
move i can only imagine the original
mecha godzilla basically yeah
how would these humans build something
that is as flexible
yeah as mobile as something like
godzilla or kong or any of the titans so
that was a big part of my question and
then just looking at that
image alone you're like oh this godzilla
this mechagodzilla like a move oh yeah
it looks flexible i don't know about
flexible camera but it's like like
his head and tail apparatus looks like
it doesn't look away
or it can move like a godzilla it looks
like it wants to be able to whip its
tail around and use that blade
on the end to cause some real damage i
mean now that we know what's really
going on since the filmmakers revealed
it themselves
when the theories were first coming out
of oh godzilla
is not attacking it's actually
mechagodzilla attacking i had a hard
time
buying how people could think that just
because like i said the original
mechagodzilla was in my head
so now seeing that if that was the film
i'd be like oh i could see that because
yeah look at the way this thing looks
like it can move
you don't want the wiggly version where
he like does a jump and the skin
disappears
maybe godzilla will or kong or one of
them will take out mecha godzilla and
then they'll go back to fighting each
other
right that's kind of where i'm at now uh
i don't think that's what's gonna happen
funny enough
my theories actually got pretty concrete
after
watching batman v superman uh the
ultimate edition the other day which by
the way
fantastic movie batman beats superman
but then superman
defeats doomsday i think godzilla
will win the fight gotta be an
undoubtable moment where they team up to
take down mechagodzilla i think
mechagodzilla might get the upper hand
over godzilla at one point and then kong
will take out mecca godzilla that's
their way of canceling it out
that's at least what i'm gonna i'm
thinking that godzilla and kong will be
like
that's what's up or something you know
yeah once you knock out mechagodzilla
if what we're hearing is to be believed
then you know you won't have the
frequency screwing with godzilla's mind
anymore so he can be like whoa whoa what
i'm sorry
man what was i doing back i just think
that godzilla will be kong
and then mechagodzilla will show up
might get the upper hand kong will beat
mecca godzilla yeah he'll probably like
land the final blow on him
and then that'll make them have like
like okay all right work together good
yeah he'll do one of those like t-rex
jaw rip fist bump and then create an
atomic blast
exploding high five right yeah
yeah see buildings obliterated people
being
disintegrated uh all right guys so what
do you think about this look at
mechagodzilla
are you as excited for it as we are
leave your thoughts down below make sure
you subscribe to 3c films as well
last but not least
jason dolan jason i'm supposed to go on
a phone call with you in roughly
four hours from now from filming this
the hell do you want to talk about
what's the mystery of
the day oh he's keeping you in suspense
so supposed to talk with the person who
he edits for as producer of for
cassie reacts a wonderful youtube
reaction channel plug there for you
that's what he wants to talk to you
about is he wants to acquire a package
of plugs
he's got spoilers there's a reason why
he wants to talk to me
not you yeah i'm the uh
probably that level of improv that's
just
oh boy i'm i'm good at other things like
it's not only important let me find the
flow where you don't have to come in
with some weird
i'm sorry jason sorry man i'm sorry i
didn't mean it jason
you know what i'll leave and you can
finish the show not just just the two of
you guys
all right now it's done